I don't think you want any help it seems
you wanna have a little pity party yeah
I think Annie wants a little pity party
you're one of the funniest actors of all
time Melissa McCarthy and it looks like
humor runs in your family because Jenny
McCarthy who happens to be your first
cousin it's pretty hilarious too back in
the 90s Jenny helped you land your first
TV role when she invited you to guest
star on the view and well the rest is
pretty much history if it hadn't been
for your last names we never would have
made the connection and the same goes
for most of the other famous family
members in this video has anyone else in
your family won an Emmy no tons of
talented stars share the spotlight with
their family members but just because
they share the same DNA doesn't
necessarily mean they share the same
dining table watch until the end to find
out which English royal has been
directly linked to Dakota and Elle
Fanning Emily Blunt and Stanley Tucci
first met in 2006 on the set of The
Devil Wears Prada and back then they had
no way of knowing that they would one
day become family four years later in
2010 Emily and John Krasinski tie the
knot at the Lake Como home of George
Clooney and Emily invited her former
co-star to her wedding and that's where
Stanley Tucci met Emily's older sister
Felicity Blunt it's easy to spot the
resemblance between Emily and Felicity
so you might be wondering why you
weren't aware that Emily had a sister in
the first place
we didn't fight that much it was more
like stupid squabbles well the truth of
the matter is that Felicity enjoys
keeping a low profile
Felicity married Stanley in 2012 they
have five children together three of
whom are from Stanley's previous
marriage so there you have it emily is
Stanley's sister-in-law emily Blunt's
wedding you meet your future wonderful
wife Hollywood is full of famous mother
and daughter duo's like zoe kravitz and
her mom Lisa Bonet and Kate Hudson and
her mom Goldie Hawn but did you know
that the legendary uma Thurman also has
a famous daughter her name is Maya Hawk
and the resemblance is uncanny if the
name Maya Hawk doesn't ring a bell
it's only a matter of time before it
does either way you probably know her as
Robin Buckley from season 3 of stranger
things she sounds awesome
she is awesome uma is known for having
collaborated with Quentin Tarantino a
handful of times and it looks like
history is going to repeat itself after
all Maya did have a role in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood but Ilima isn't Maya's
only famous parent her father is Ethan
Hawke after all my your parents are in
the business did they give all they are
they Diana Ross is one of the most
popular singers in the world she's so
famous she transcends generations she
was inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame in 1988 so yeah she's a pretty
big deal but did you know that one of
Diana's daughters is also a celebrity
that's right
actress Tracee Ellis Ross is the icons
daughter and she bears a striking
resemblance to her mother Tracey has
starred in popular TV shows like
girlfriends and blackish it changed her
polling place closely didn't want to
make it harder for us to find him and
she's a famous producer too but wait
Howard Tracy and Diana linked to Ashley
Simpson well through marriage of course
turns out Diana's youngest son Evan tied
the knot with Ashley in 2014
Ashley gets to call Diana Ross her
mother-in-law now how cool is that this
is my family back in 2012 Award winning
actor Halle Berry revealed some very
surprising news during an interview with
extra according to the star she's
distantly related to Sarah Palin the
former governor of Alaska according to
Halle she and Sarah are connected
through her mother's side of the family
although Sarah and Holly's family tree
might connected the roots both of these
ladies have very different political
views and Holly isn't about to reach out
anytime soon on a side note holly is
believed to be related to the Queen of
Soul Aretha Franklin through her
father's side of the family are--this
family has revealed the connection
stating that Hollies grandmother and a
Rita's grandmother were first cousins
Halle isn't the only star to receive
mind-blowing news when it comes to her
family tree keep watching to find out
which a-list actor Justin Bieber is
reportedly related to you why what is it
add like a DNA
actor Jonah Hill has been making us
laugh since he first made waves in 2004
Jonah's real name is Jonah Hill
Feldstein that he chose to drop his last
name when entering the industry it
wasn't until early 2020 that fans made
the connection between Jonah and his
sister beanie Feldstein but now that the
truth is out everyone's freaking out
beanie is just as hilarious as her
brother she played Norah in neighbours
two sorority rising and Julie in Lady
Bird but most recently beanie portrayed
molly in the film book-smart we are
smart and fun a performance that
resulted in a Golden Globe nomination
now that the world has finally puts you
in two together fans are excited to one
day see the famous brother-sister duo
share the big screen but Jonah and
beanie aren't the only famous siblings
in their family as it turns out they had
a brother named Jordan who sadly passed
away in 2018 he was a celebrated music
manager who had worked with maroon 5
since the very beginning Jordan had also
worked with musicians like Elle King and
a Rick Springfield Jonah Hill still
finds his brother's death painful to
talk about Thomas brodie-sangster is an
English actor who keeps a low profile
despite working on some major
productions in 2013 Thomas made
headlines when he starred as Jojen Reed
in the popular TV series Game of Thrones
and just one year later Thomas was cast
as Newt in The Maze Runner franchise Tom
is known for his youthful appearance
you may never know that the star turns
30 in May of 2020 Thomas has been acting
since he was 11 years old you might
recognize him from the movie Love
Actually in which he played a lovestruck
middle school kid named Sam in this film
Hugh Grant portrays the prime minister
who happens to be Sam's uncle but did
you know that Hugh and Thomas are
related in real life too turns out these
two stars are second cousins this might
come as a surprise considering that they
have a 29 year age gap between them but
it's the truth Thomas who is known for
voicing Ferb and the Phineas and Ferb
franchise shares the same DNA as the
king of rom-coms oh you oh that's great
that's good that's it's wonderful going
back to school at your hey
yes what do Justin Bieber Avril Lavigne
and Ryan Gosling have in common they're
all famous Canadians
that's what but that's not all back in
January of 2019 Justin Bieber revealed
that he was distant cousins with both
Ryan and Avril Justin found this out by
using ancestry.com
and immediately posted his findings on
Instagram with the caption this is the
best day of my life
the popstar posted a graph that proved
that Ryan was his 11th cousin removed
turned out Ryan and Justin were even
born in the same hospital you lost me
there
Bieber's mother Pattie Mallette is
related to Thomas Gosling who is Ryan's
father what are the odds of that now
that we think of it Ryan and Justin do
sort of look alike and let's not forget
that these celebrities both got their
start at a very young age so it looks
like talent does run in the family and
the same can be said about Avril Lavigne
who happens to be Justin's 12th cousin
removed Avril was just as surprised as
Justin by the connection and she reached
out to him online stating that this year
she'd be hosting Christmas supper
there's like more love than ever
stellan skarsgård is a Swedish actor who
has starred in dozens of huge
productions he's delivered amazing
performances in award-winning movies
like Good Will Hunting The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo and the Avengers he's a
classic a list actor who doubles as a
family man we're not kidding around
stellen literally has six children and
believe it or not but two of them are
well on their way to becoming just as
famous as their dad if not more first up
is Alexander Skarsgard you might know
him as Eric Northman from True Blood or
John Clayton from The Legend of Tarzan
Alexander also portrayed Perry right on
the TV series big little lies down food
up up - and then there's his younger
brother Bill skarsgård who is both a
model and an actor he's been acting
since he was a kid and obviously he's
just as talented as his dad bill landed
his first major role in 2013 when he was
cast as Roman Godfrey in the TV series
Hemlock Grove then in 2017 don't manage
to snag the role of penny wise in the
horror movie it both bill and his
brother Alex
we'll be starring in the upcoming movie
the Northman so keep an eye out for this
famous brother duo okay how can we make
this different Miley Cyrus got her start
on the Disney Channel when she was cast
as Miley Stewart on the hit TV show
Hannah Montana
Miley's Dad portrayed her father on the
show so everyone already knew that she
was related to the famous country singer
Billy Ray Cyrus what they didn't know
however was that Miley was linked to
Dolly Parton in more ways than one
throughout her career as an actor and
singer Miley has experimented with many
different genres but she never strays
too far from her country roots she's a
southern gal after all this is something
that Miley and Dolly have in common
oh that and the fact that Dolly Parton
is Miley's godmother Miley is dear to me
I think knowledge were the most talented
people I know Billie chose to make dolly
his daughter's godmother because of
their close relationship and to this
very day
Miley calls the country icon her fairy
godmother the pop star has received some
heat for her unpredictable ways in the
past but dolly has always had her back
that's what family is for right and I
just love her to pieces I'm glad she's
mine Dakota and Elle Fanning are two of
the most famous siblings in Hollywood
they were born in America but they have
a strong British background Dakota
started acting when she was just a kid
and her younger sister L soon followed
in her footsteps Elle is well known for
portraying Princess Aurora in the
Maleficent franchise but as it turns out
playing a princess isn't exactly a
stretch for the actor should have asked
me to marry him after all she does have
some royal DNA running through her veins
the siblings who will be playing
on-screen sisters for the first time in
the upcoming movie the nightingale have
been linked to the Duchess of Cambridge
Kate Middleton according to ancestry.com
they're Kate's 21st cousins
Oh and they're also descendants of King
Edward the first inspirational yes for
me which of these secret celebrity
liaisons surprised you the most tell us
in the comments give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more we'll see you next time thanks
for watching
you